it is a town like so many others like
too many others reduced in parts to
rubble
borodyanka had a population before the
war of about 13 000. that's the size of
summerside pei port hope ontario kenmore
alberta or alder grove bc
now what all of those places share with
this one is this
main street just flying over it doesn't
let you appreciate how everything that
was here was like what most of us know
wherever we live
so
starting out at the traffic circle
there's a restaurant on the right
sasha's place has a facebook page you
can see their courtyard
their food
and their staff behind sasha's there was
a building supply store there are some
great reviews online the owner natalka
could get you anything and you'd
apparently be pleasantly surprised by
the prices
further up there was a small gourmet
grocery store the sort of place you
might go if you needed a special
ingredient
on the left side there was a hardware
store part of a chain judging from the
pictures the sort of place my brother
would like moving on there was a beer
store on the right a place called
barboss directly across from a health
clinic by the way hold up medical with
all the specialists you might need if
you were looking for a cell phone that
was a bit further up keith starr seems
to have had a decent selection there was
also a good selection at the butcher
shop across the street a block from
there another hardware store this one
with an interesting name mario's
hardware yes that mario there was
another beer store but this one a little
different you could buy draft from the
top
the local tax office was just up the
street and then a sports storm a very
crowded and colorful sports store which
brings us to the town square it's
another thing most communities have and
in the case of bordeanca in the middle
there was a statue ukrainian poet and
artist taras shivchenko
this is what that square looks like
today and how that statue was left with
a bullet hole in the head and looking
down almost as though trying not to see
what happened here according to
ukrainian officials russian troops
killed 300 people in bourdienko 50 of
them
executed
mike armstrong global news